[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge von place to be stars & stories
seinem wöchentlichen update zu all den
promis denen du in den sozialen
netzwerken folgst und da gab es diese
woche genau ein thema was alle stars wie
heidi klum justin bieber und co
beschäftigt hat nämlich der tod des afro
amerikaners george dazu habe ich mit nba
star dennis schröder gesprochen
viele leute einfach schwarze leute
dunkelhäutige leute und ungerecht
behandeln wirklich sehr sehr aggressive
methoden anwenden ohne grund ist es halt
die gesagt schockieren und den ganzen
tag gibt es gleich jetzt gibt es erstmal
das weekly update
[Musik]
der tod von george j hat die ganze welt
erschüttert und eine riesige welle der
solidarität ausgelöst nicht nur online
teilen die menschen ihre anteilnahme
unter dem hashtag black lies meter sie
gehen auch auf die straße an
öffentlichen demonstrationen haben
bereits stars wie ariana green day die
sänger schon mendes und camille akw
model emily radkovsky oder der riverdale
schauspieler kohls braus teilgenommen
der wurde dabei sogar festgenommen
auf instagram schreibt er dass es ihm
wichtig sei seine verhaftung nicht zum
mittelpunkt der berichterstattung zu
machen sondern die sache für die er
demonstriert habe als heterosexueller
weißer mann der in der öffentlichkeit
steht sind die konsequenzen nichts im
vergleich zu dem was anderen
demonstranten passiert dies ist und
bleibt eine zeit in der es darum geht
anderen zu unterstützen aufklärung zu
leisten zu demonstrieren und das
richtige zu tun
wer am dienstag seinen instagram feed
geöffnet hat hat wahrscheinlich nur
schwarze bilder gesehen grund dafür
unter dem motto der show must be post
rief die us-musikindustrie zum blackout
tuesday auf neben zahlreichen social
media nutzern animierten auch viele
stars dazu die gesamte aufmerksamkeit an
diesem tag auf ungerechtigkeit und
rassismus zu lenken so auch die sängerin
rihanna basketballspieler lebron james
sänger justin bieber youtube ihren agb
model carl levin musiker nico santos und
viele viele mehr
der hashtag black out you stay wurde bei
instagram fast 30 millionen mal geteilt
das sagt model toni dreher dazu
mit an einer wichtigsten zeige dieses
jahr nicht nur für mich sondern auch
wirklich viele leute glaube ich auch da
draußen und zu sehen wäre wirklich teil
von ihrem liebling ist wer support wer
auch gegen rassismus ist und ich finde
es war wirklich eine schöne möglichkeit
auch zu sehen
wie viele leute man dazu bewegen kann
für eine sache einzustehen und ich
glaube das hat auch wirklich gewöhnt und
ich hoffe ich wünsche mir
etwas ist was nicht einfach so
vorübergeht oder unter den teppich
gekehrt wird sondern dass es der beginn
von etwas ist was wirklich veränderungen
vorbringt und es ist auch sehr wichtig
dass alle wissen das ist kein kampf ist
zwischen schwarz und weiß in schwarz
oder so sondern das ist wirklich ein
kampf in dem alle gegen rassismus führen
und das war es auch im vordergrund steht
wir wollen das ist es in dieser heutigen
seite hier und jetzt nicht mehr
akzeptiert durch die aktuellen
geschehnisse drücken auch einige stars
ihre sorge aus wie wohl die zukunft
ihres nachwuchses aussehen wird
basketball-superstar dirk nowitzki
schrieb bei twitter dass er am boden
zerstört sei und angst um die zukunft
seiner kinder habe nowitzki hat mit
seiner ehefrau jessica olsson eine
tochter und zwei söhne
model heidi klum veröffentlichte ein
foto auf dem ihre hände die ihres
ehemanns tom und die ihrer kinder zu
sehen sind und teilt ein zitat von
martin luther king in dem er sich eine
friedliche zukunft für seine vier kinder
wünscht heidi schrieb dass sie denselben
traum habe auch für die
us-schauspielerin jamie postete ein foto
von ihrem mann und ihrer tochter und
zeigt sich hoffnungsvoll dass die
nächsten generationen die vorurteile der
vergangenheit abschaffen können auch in
der bundesliga zeigten mehrere
fußballprofis ihre solidarität zum
getöteten george bvb-profis ante und
hakimi trugen die nachricht justice for
george floyd unter ihren trikots schals
mit teenie trug eine schwarze
trauerbinden mit der aufschrift justice
for george laut dfb regeln sind
botschaften auf der ausrüstung
eigentlich verboten aber der
kontrollausschuss gab bereits bekannt
dass keiner der spieler für seine
solidarische aktion bestraft werde
das gelte auch für mögliche
antirassismus botschaften an den
kommenden spieltagen passend zum thema
durfte ich mit keinem geringeren als nba
star dennis schröder sprechen
[Musik]
alles gut also wir sind gerade noch
immer klar meine familie und ich sehr
gutes wetter aber den umständen
entsprechend zeitnah also sehr sehr viel
im laufe gerade hier wie hast du die
fotos und videos ja was haben sie bei
die ausgelöst wie hast du die
wahrgenommen als etwas gesehen hast
gesehen als erstes glaube ich bei
instagram wir dann brauch ich glaube
alle an allen freunden den ich den ich
folge die haben wir alle stories
gepostet bilder hochgeladen
ja sehr traurig sehr traurig zu sehen
ich glaube es ist halt immer schwierig
leute so zu sehen oder überhaupt
menschen die die die anderen menschen so
etwas antun können also ich war schon
schockiert und natürlich traurig auch
das motto unter dem die bewegung steht
polizeigewalt gegen afro-amerikaner und
gegen rassismus ein ende zu setzen oder
natürlich aber ich glaube was jetzt die
letzten jahre passiert ist videos die
gepostet wurden in den nachrichten die
sachen dass er viele leute einfach
schwarze leute dunkelhäutige leute und
ungerecht behandeln wirklich sehr sehr
aggressive methoden anwenden ohne grund
ist es halt wie gesagt schockierend und
es ist sehr sehr traurig das ist halt so
bei uns also hier gerade herrscht heißt
das ist ich glaube die community muss
auf jeden fall was dagegen machen
du kannst du viel im alltag davon
nämlich wirklich also es ist ganz normal
ihr hier ist es perfekt aber was halt in
den staaten los ist in vielen städten
ist halt natürlich nicht nicht gut
du bist ja eigentlich in deutschland
aufgewachsenen du kommst aus
braunschweig ursprünglich
ja wenn ich so direkt fragen darf hast
du in der zeit in deutschland irgendwie
erfahrungen mit rassismus machen müssen
ja na klar also im kindergarten waren
halt schon die ersten situation wo leute
mich gefragt haben warum meine haut zu
dreckig ist und was auch immer noch dazu
kam
aber ich mein kind bist du einfach
ehrlich und du weißt halt nichts von der
situation und das du dann halt frags ok
warum warum bist du dunkel warum ist
deine haut dreckig kann man denen dann
halt zu der zeit nicht übel nehmen
aber es ist natürlich alles verstand man
habe mir gedacht warum fragte das weil
ich meine dass wahrheit zu der zeit als
ich meine ich war der einzige im
kindergarten auch der dunkelhäutig war
deswegen natürlich hat man sich da ein
paar fragen gestellt
aber natürlich hat nachhinein wenn ich
darüber überlege weiß ist okay die
kinder die haben halt nachgefragt weil
sie halt nicht wissen warum es so ist
und da konntest das also jetzt denke ich
darüber nach und da was kann ich es
nicht übelnehmen
aber im endeffekt in der schule wenn man
älter wird das ist halt auch eine
erziehungssache denke ich von eltern
lehrern den mitzuteilen wie es
eigentlich sein sollte
und ja da hat sich auf jeden fall auch
viele viele situationen wo leute mich
bestimmt haben
und ja das war war war nicht schön auf
jeden fall ganz viele fußballer und
sportler generell ihre solidarität zum
ausdruck gebracht dass am trikots
getragen wo der aufstand vor george
wright was würdest du sagen welche rolle
spielen sportler im kampf gegen
rassismus
spielt eine sehr große rolle ich glaube
dass jeder aussagekraft hat einfluss hat
auf die welt ich glaube dass also kerpen
eckball entdeckt er hat ein sehr sehr
gutes beispiel hat er allen sportlern
gezeigt und er wurde natürlich dafür
bestraft dass halt nicht mehr mgr in der
nfl spielen kann
papanek footballspieler bei der hymne
ist er halt auf die knie gegangen war
heute halt dass irgendetwas passiert
dass leute darüber spricht und im
endeffekt ist das dann halt nach hinten
los gegangen und er hat halt kein
nfl-team mehr gehabt und bis jetzt zum
heutigen tag hat halt immer noch kein
team und aber ich glaube wenn halt alle
in die community gehen und alle sportler
wirklich sagen okay so und so sollten
wir vorgehen
dann würde es auf jeden fall was
bewirken aber alleine da nur dass er das
halt macht ist das hat also natürlich
was gebracht
für viele leute aber es hat halt nicht
leute haben nicht mal darüber geredet
dieses ganze tolle gespräch mit ihr
jetzt nicht nur in dieser schweren
gespräch lage zeiten muss ich es
unbedingt noch sagen weil du etwas total
positives gemacht hast du hast deinen
heimatverein die löwen braunschweig
ich würde sagen man kann so sagen du
hast sie gerettet
ab dem ersten juli er wirst du
hauptgesellschafter ja also es war eine
schwierige zeit die letzten vier bis
sechs wochen waren wir in sehr sehr
vielen gesprächen
mein team und ich konnten natürlich den
braunschweiger fein nicht an die wand
fahren lassen also ja ich bin da
hochgekommen habe jugend gespielt habe
dort in der zweiten bundesliga ersten
bundesliga gespielt
das ist schon eine herzensangelegenheit
für mich das zu machen und die natürlich
zu retten und
yokohama wie kommt da noch dieser diese
heimatverbundenheit her dass du da noch
so an dem klub hengst also ich bin dort
durch die jugend gegangen habe
bundesligaspiele gemacht und allein die
stadt weil ich dort geboren bin
die ganzen fans die jedes spiel dort
waren um nicht zu supporten natürlich
wenn man halt so was sie dass sie durch
eine corona krise durch die krise
probleme haben für nächstes jahr also
eine lizenz zu bekommen
bis das halt keine frage für mich mich
da zu engagieren und zu sagen okay ich
werde auf jeden fall helfen es ist für
mich halt sehr wichtig einfach dass
basketball in braunschweig weiter geht
der natürlich also im sommer bin ich
eigentlich zwei bis drei monate bin ich
immer in braunschweig versucht halt so
viel wie möglich zu machen immer
versuchen irgendwie zum prinzenpark zu
kommen ist ein basketballplatz wo ich ja
früher immer gespielt habe versuchen
dort mit fans zu spielen
fotos zu machen autogramme zu geben und
natürlich auch bei den löwen jetzt da
werde ich auch mehr mein gesicht zeigen
und mich dort engagieren und ja das wird
auf jeden fall eine sehr gute zeit jetzt
also wir haben es wurden uns dass wir
jetzt der gmbh fortführen werden
ich glaube ende juli werden wir das
erste spiel haben da sind wir natürlich
alle auf jeden fall excited dass wir
wieder spielen dürfen waren zweieinhalb
monate jetzt zu hause und habe nichts
gemacht
bayern verfolgt dortmund verfolgt habe
ja natürlich da
viele kollegen mit denen ich sehr gut
bin und natürlich sofort zu ist und es
hat auch natürlich gut getan
für die welt überhaupt mal wieder sport
zu sehen im fernsehen alles gute für die
nächsten spiele
danke schön danke tschüss so unsere
inspiration of the week kommt dieses mal
von den ganz kleinen von denen sich
viele eine scheibe abschneiden könnten
[Musik]
wenn ich das für fresh & easy
ich bin trotzdem seien die dienste laut
hersteller
ja das war auch schon die erste folge
von place to be stars & stories
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder
[Musik]